[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du cetud culture aujourd'hui nous
sommes à la batterie de guyancourt lieux
culturels incontournables de la ville et
anciennes batteries militaire qui date
de 1879 mais avant cela voici le
sommaire à guyancourt la batterie a
entamé sa saison 2021 2022 nous
parlerons avec l'un des membres de
l'équipe qui présentera la programmation
de cette année une nouvelle chorale
d'enfants vient d'ouvrir ses portes à
viroflay dirigé par magali d'ange chef
de choeur professionnel cette petite
troupe explore un répertoire éclectique
et puis enfin au musée de la ville de
saint quentin en yvelines l'exposition
vient jouer dehors est à découvrir
jusqu'au 15 janvier prochain
[Musique]
on
je me trouve dans l'auditorium de la
batterie à guyancourt ici sont
rassemblés une école de musique de
salles de concert et 3 studios de
répétition yoann est lavable bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le directeur de la
ferme de bel ébat et le programmateur de
la batterie alors est ce que vous êtes
heureux la saison 2021 est lancé heureux
de retrouver le public bah oui parce que
ça a été c'était une période difficile
effectivement de voir rester fermée
aussi longtemps donc retrouver le public
c'est une grande joie et c'est notre
raison d'être c'est pour ça c'est pour
ça qu'on est là donc ça fait beaucoup de
bien est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
nous parler de la programmation
justement à venir cette saison oui alors
c'est cette programmation de
l'auditorium
a une spécificité
je dirais très rare c'est une
programmation on en est très fier qui
est strictement paritaire donc sur sûre
dans cette salle vous aurez autant de
concerts dans les musiques sont écrites
par des femmes que par des hommes ça a
l'air de rien comme ça quand on le dit
mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
97% des musiques qui sont diffusés dans
les salles en france sont composées par
des hommes et donc nous on a on a eu à
coeur de respecter la parité on va
retrouver des musiques dans des styles
variés à la fois de la chanson à la fois
de la musique classique du jazz des
musiques du monde et puis des musiques
pour tous les âges il ya des concerts
voilà dédié à l'enfance et d'autres pour
un public plus adulte alors on me disait
un seul lieu et à ses incontournables
quand on parle de musique à guyancourt
est-ce que la batterie aussi peut-être
pour but de faire émerger de nouveaux
artistes oh oui je crois que c'est la
vocation de salle municipale aussi de
savoir être au rendez-vous pour
permettre à des artistes qui ne sont pas
encore là d'une grande notoriété de de
faire leurs premiers pas dans la vie
professionnelle donc effectivement on
accompagne l'émergence de nouveaux
artistes même si au programme également
des artistes reconnus de stature
internationale mais c'est important de
trouver un équilibre entre les deux
alors justement vous allez rester avec
nous puisque là on va découvrir
un de vos spectacles la belle et la bête
donc musique et contes mélangé avec du
violoncelle du on voit donc regarder ces
sujets
des airs de musique entraînant et
enivrant le conte la belle et la bête
était mise en musique à la batterie de
guyancourt sur scène quatre instruments
flûte hautbois violoncelle et accordéon
donc ce qui donne des timbres très très
particulier et est vraiment très riche
aussi une adaptation du texte de madame
leprince de beaumont qui a été mis en
musique par diane bezan et frédéric
unterfinger et c'est déjà une adaptation
du texte pour concorder avec la musique
un récitant vient accompagner la musique
le texte est en symbiose avec les quatre
instruments de musique
[Musique]
là bas je suis pas particulièrement de
musiciens donc évidemment il a fallu que
j'écoute particulièrement le travail de
mes collègues pour être sûr qu'on puisse
être bien ensemble et puis après c'est
vraiment un travail de partitions donc
c'est exactement comme au trail de
musiciens les mots sont écrits sur la
partition sur les notes quasiment tous
les musiciens viennent de saint quentin
en yvelines comme lobbyiste et le
flûtiste qui sont professeurs dans
l'école de musique de guyancourt ce soir
là une centaine de spectateurs étaient
présents j'ai beaucoup aimé ce spectacle
parce que j'ai trouvé que la mise en
musique avec le narrateur créer un
moment vraiment magique ce spectacle
j'ai trouvé absolument vraiment
magnifique on était absorbé dans
l'histoire emporter par la musique les
quatre instruments
se marier vraiment superbement les
musiciens de la belle et la bête espère
pouvoir rejouer ce spectacle dans les
mois à venir pour de nouveaux publics à
la rioja nord vient de voir le reportage
est ce que peut être vous pouvez nous
donner trois temps forts de la
programmation à suivre oui alors c'est
quand même un crève coeur en choisir que
trois parce que j'ai envie de vous dire
moi on a une vingtaine de concerts et je
les aime tous et je les défends tous
avec la même ardeur mais bon puisque le
jeu c'est d'en choisir 3 je vous
parlerai en janvier d'une création
puisque c'est comme ça je vais faire un
opéra tout seul et donc ce serait une
création jeune public de claire diterzi
qu'on attend là pas forcément dans ce
contexte la claire diterzi une
musicienne vraiment pas dire polymorphe
c'est un spectacle en partenariat avec
le le centre dramatique national de
sartrouville et des yvelines dans le
cadre du festival odyssée en yvelines et
donc voilà je vous parlais tout à
l'heure de programmation paritaire et à
quel point ça nous tient à coeur et là
c'est l'histoire d'un homme d'une jeune
fille à qui on dit que les grandes
compositrice ça n'a jamais existé et
cette jeune fille se rebelle et elle dit
bref puisque c'est comme ça moi je vais
faire un opéra tout seul et à la 22e
temps forts alors on va rester toujours
sur notre notre histoire de matrimoine
de l'héritage culturel féminin avec un
concert original qu'on propose en
partenariat avec la scène nationale
de saint quentin en yvelines et ça
s'appelle un piano révolutionnaire et là
on vous permettra au public de découvrir
le répertoire des laines de montgeroult
une compositrice
malheureusement inconnu qu'on souhaite
faire redécouvrir
qui a eu un destin assez assez étonnant
c'est une marquise et une aristocrate
donc elle ne pouvait pas jouer en public
ses oeuvres et puis la révolution est
arrivée elle n de montgeroult est passé
devant le comité de salut public où elle
a bien failli être
guillotiné et elle a demandé à ce qu'on
fasse venir un piano et sur un piano
elle s'est lancée dans une incroyable
improvisation sur les thèmes de la
marseillaise est alors le comité de
salut public s'est dit non c'est pas
possible on peut pas condamner à mort
quelqu'un qui a autant de talent et
hélène de montgeroult est devenue la
première professeur de piano pour hommes
du conservatoire national et troisième
temps fort avec la le 3 mai dernier elle
va on va aller à la frontière entre en
trouver les frontières s'estompent de
plus en plus entre les styles musicaux
et c'est un grand bonheur et là c'est
leïla leïla martial et rémi leclerc qui
sont partis faire un voyage en afrique
et ils ont rencontré une tribu la tribu
aka qui est une tribu célèbre pour ses
chants polyphoniques et donc ils
viendront le 20 avril à l'auditorium
on retrouvera donc cette vocaliste
également des percussions corporelles et
ils viennent accompagné de cinq
musiciens pygmées de la tribu à 4 est
bien on sera là merci beaucoup y en a
marre d'avoir été notre invité merci à
vous
[Musique]
et nous restons à guyancourt une
exposition et des ateliers sont à
découvrir jusqu'au 30 octobre paysage
est présentée à la salle d'exposition de
guyancourt en partenariat avec
l'établissement public d'aménagement
paris saclay des plasticiens des
photographes et une romancière graphique
dévoile au public leur vision du projet
du plateau de saclay connaissez-vous les
mystères du cerveau jusqu'au 21 octobre
à la maison de quartier auguste renoir
une conférence atelier est animé par
l'association braillenet pour connaître
les différentes fonctions de la mémoire
et savoir comment l'entraîné facilement
d'autres ateliers expositions et
spectacles sont à découvrir jusqu'au 23
octobre la petite fabrique c'est le nom
de cette nouvelle chorale d'enfants à
viroflay âgés de 7 à 11 ans tous les
mercredis les petits amateurs explore un
répertoire complet entre jazz variété ou
encore rock classique magali l'ange chef
de choeur professionnel dirige cette
petite amp
c'est bon bon bon
[Musique]
c'est bon bon bon des petites voix qui
s'exerce et découvre le chant depuis
plus d'un mois ce choeur d'enfants
répète une fois par semaine pendant 1h30
et apprend les secrets du rythme et de
la musique c'est bien quand elle chante
j'aime bien la chance ou et j'aime bien
quand chez les athées j'adore sont faits
depuis tout petit et je prends du
plaisir en son temps on a appris les
prénoms de tout le monde
elles prennent bien beau chanter huit
enfants de 6 à 11 ans font aujourd'hui
partie de cette association la petite
fabrique est lancée en 2020 par deux
amis environ
c'est né d'une envie commune où on et
choristes mais on est aussi maman et le
plaisir que l'on trouve en scène de long
de longue date avec magali ou même dans
des expériences antérieures
quelque chose de communicatif et qu on
avait aussi envie de transmettre
en fait ils ont une partie à la fois de
créativité et à la fois petit actis
synchronise plus fort à la direction
magali l'ange chanteuse depuis l'âge de
11 ans choristes professionnels le chef
de choeur damier les enfants d'abord à
s'ouvrir alors purement d'abord
musicalement va on va interpréter et
écouter on a fait aussi de l' écoute de
musique classique de rock de jazz on
fera des musiques du monde des chansons
dans plusieurs langues mais plus
globalement c'est aussi que l'enfant
s'empare de tous qui sait faire
oralement de son corps les ateliers de
chant choral sont accompagnés de mise en
scène et de solfège un joli grain ou
tout simplement une envie de chanter la
petite fabrique accepte de nouvelles
voies sans audition d'entrée
depuis le 16 octobre l'espace maurice
béjart de verneuil sur seine a rouvert
ses portes après plus de trois mois de
travaux la salle de spectacles et de
cinéma d'accueillir de nouveaux du
public vendredi 22 octobre c'est
l'humoriste thomas wiesel qui foulera en
premier le tout nouveau sol de l'espace
avec son one man show ça va au musée de
la ville de saint quentin en yvelines
l'exposition 20 jouer dehors présente la
naissance des aires de jeux en milieu
urbain des années 1960 1970
l'exposition est visible jusqu'au 15
janvier
[Musique]
c'est une réelle immersion dans le monde
de l'enfance que nous propose le musée
de la ville de saint quentin en yvelines
objets images d'archivés photographies
nous présente des aires de jeux de la
fin des années 60 à la fin des années 70
c'est sans doute la caractéristique de
ces jeux par rapport à aux jeux
contemporains sont fondés sur des formes
relativement simple mais qui incite
beaucoup plus l'enfant un travail
d'imagination et l'appropriation
personnelle les pièces majeures
proviennent des espaces publics de jeu
de saint quentin en yvelines et ont été
pensés par plusieurs créateurs vient
donc les voir ne sont les simonet est
aussi le groupe ludique c'est la
troisième pièce monumentale qu'on
présente dans l'exposition qu'on nomme
serpent qui a été réalisé par donc
marthe et jean mary simonet qui sont
donc des des créateurs qui ont toute
leur vie travailler à la fois le
matériau plastique par par moulage et
qui on proposait des forme modulaire
véritable reflet de l'enfance dans ces
années-là ces jeux s'inscrivent dans une
période de l'histoire durant laquelle en
donner aux enfants une liberté beaucoup
plus grande les populations vont vers
les villes et les enfants de ces villes
ont besoin d'un espace créé récréatif
donc de jeu pour retrouver un petit peu
dans les espaces urbains ce qu'ils
pouvaient faire originalement dans les
campagnes c'est à dire grappes escalader
se cacher pour les vacances de la
toussaint vous pourrez également
découvrir deux activités au musée de la
ville ville en herbe le mercredi 27
octobre et sculptures dans la ville le
samedi 30 octobre et c'est la fin de ce
set 8 culture merci de nous avoir suivis
rendez-vous à la semaine prochaine dans
un autre lieu culturel yves binois bonne
soirée sur tv5 118
[Musique]